[Musique]
nous allons parler du paris dakar que
vous venez d'évoquer puisque les cinq
cent cinquante concurrents partiront de
la place d'armes de versailles le 1er
janvier
parmi ses concurrents il ya beaucoup de
vedettes et parmi ces vedettes un jeune
chanteur qui s'appelle daniel balavoine
il sera le numéro 220 il pilotera avec
un garçon qui s'appelle jean luc roy et
daniel balavoine a bien l'intention
qu'on le prenne au sérieux dans cette
aventure
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a dit à
sylvie jos
ouais je m'appelle balavoine
j'suis navigateur et pilotte et lui et
moi je m'appelle jean luc roy je suis
pilote et un navigateur
voilà
[Musique]
et
non seulement balavoine n'est pas un
héros mais en plus ils insistent sur le
fait qu'ils ne participent pas au dakar
pour suivre une mode et se montrer je
participe au paris dakar à mon avis pour
à peu près les mêmes raisons que les
trois quarts des gens qui le font c'est
à dire pour le sport pour le voyage pour
l' aventure pour l'amour de la voiture
pour l'afrique pour la beauté du paysage
pour rencontrer des gens différents pour
gemma pour vivre autre chose pour
prendre des vacances pour prendre de
l'air pur pas avoir de téléphone dans la
voiture pour pour plein de choses pour
conduire vite pour essayer de naviguer
et démons camarades à conduire vite
qu'est ce que je peux vous faire
d'autres encore c'est à dire si vous
demandez ça aux autres personnes qu'ils
font je pense qu'ils auront pendant à
peu près la même chose avec son ami jean
luc roy il a préparé la voiture réglages
techniques entraînement sur circuit tout
terrain pendant la course chacun sera à
tour de rôle pilote et copilote jean luc
roy effectuera 70% du parcours au volant
daniel balavoine pilotera pendant les
étapes de liaison qu'il fera également
quelques épreuves spéciales l'équipage
roi balavoine c'est la bonne humeur et
la confiance mutuelles confiance en lui
la il tourne pas mal on a on a regardé
la voiture de près je sais qui conduit
très bien il a l'habitude de conduire
des voitures rapides très rapide même
peut-être trop rapide mais en fait ça
marche a eu des pièces et en fait j'ai
une totale confiance en vous avez
confiance à jean luc roy pas du tout moi
par contre je vais bien sûr selon partir
est ensemble
la seule crainte de daniel balavoine
avant le départ et de s'égarer dans le
désert et de perdre un temps précieux
aussi at-il méticuleusement mis au point
ces cartes il révise son road book tous
les soirs et pratiquement incollable sur
le maniement de la boussole
et
l'objectif est d'arriver à dakar si
possible avec un classement honorable
[Musique]
par le même pas il ya deux courses dans
le rallye celle des porsche des audi et
des lada dont on parle et derrière il va
y avoir les 4,4 rapide et disons que
nous on vient encore un petit peu après
donc au départ il faudra pas nous
chercher avant la 50e place
j'espère directrice des contrats voilà
au départ daniel balavoine c'est qu'il
est un privilégié dans ce rallye mais le
paris dakar il le fait d'abord pour le
plaisir
[Musique]
bien
à
[Musique]